kamino accidentally stumbles upon Claire
while she was bathing in the hot spring
he notices Claire's short height and
small bust and states that he isn't
interested in those things
in response Claire reveals that she's
only 16 and attacks Cameo with her whip
as comido Dodges her attacks he
unintentionally comments on her body
causing her to become angrier and slice
off the trunk of a large tree with her
whip as Claire is about to be crushed by
the falling tree Cognito rushes and
manages to save her just in time however
while In the Heat of the Moment his hand
inadvertently brushes against her chest
area further fueling her anger causing
her to lash out and continue attacking
him until he becomes unconscious upon
waking up kamita finds himself with a
wit collar around his neck with Claire
declaring him a high grade pervert
apologizes and informs her of his letter
from greyworth the director of a racist
Spirit Academy while walking around
Claire reveals that she came to the
forest to make a contract with a sealed
Spirit she then takes kamio to a shrine
where the powerful spirit that killed
the late Demon King is sealed with the
barrier broken by her spell they entered
a shrine where the sword lies on a table
she tries to make a contract with the
sealed Spirit but it goes wild and
starts attacking Claire summons Scarlet
her spirit to bite the frenzy sword and
attacks it with Fireball Spirit magic
unfortunately the sword stabs scarlet
and stuns her kamido then makes a
contract with the sword Spirit to save
scarlet and Claire later they leave for
a racist Spirit Academy where Claire
tells him that he's her slave Spirit he
manages to escape from her and goes to
greyworth there he meets Ellis leader of
the silford who Corners him and asks him
what he's doing in an all-girls Academy
but greyworth manages to get Ellis to
give him a tour of the academy and his
new home
in Raven class he teases Claire but is
caught and reprimanded by their teacher
Freya during class Claire and her
classmate rinselet fight over who gets
to keep kamido as their slave before he
accidentally stuffs his face and rinsely
its maid Carol's opai later greyworth
says that she wants him to participate
in the upcoming blade dance because Ren
ashebell has returned and is going to
bring a dark Elemental spirit with her
later his old contracted spirit restia
is seen landing on the roof of the
racist Spirit Academy with a smile
kamita was lying down in his stable
thinking about his conversation with
greyworth where she told him that he is
going to participate in the blade dance
a marshall tournament held every five
years if he wins then he'll be granted
the protection of a spirit Lord as well
as any one wish renzla enters bringing a
plate of soup with her and tells kamido
that she'll give it to him if he barks
like a dog and agrees to be her servant
he shuts the door on her and says that
he'll pass but she still gives him the
food and is about to head back when
Claire returns and insults her asking
why she fed her contracted Spirit
rinslet takes offense and they start
battling over who gets to keep kamito as
their slave but abruptly stop when they
destroy his house Ellis appears along
with two other Knights and tells them
that they are not permitted to battle
inside the school premises Claire
challenges the three of them to an
official duel that will take place in
the night and rinselet and kamido join
her team Claire then takes commuto to
her room and goes to take a bath while
he cooks dinner while taking a shower
she gets attacked by the water spirit
but kamido intervenes and saves her at
dinner Camino asks her why she wants to
make a contract with strong spirits she
tells him that it's because she wants to
meet her elder sister again
Camino then proceeds to ask her the real
truth about why she is known as a
traitor to their Kingdom they later
traveled astral zero an area designated
for duels and battles at the location
rinslick reads them followed by Ellis
and her companions a few minutes later
Camuto engages in a battle with Ellis
calling forth his sword only to find it
smaller than anticipated meanwhile
rinslit and Claire successfully defeat
Ellis's two allies as the fight between
kamido and Ellison sues restia descends
from the sky accompanied by a demonic
Spirit which awakens comedo's true
potential seeing that powerful the
spirit Claire decides that she's going
to make a contract with it and starts
fighting it but she soon gets winded
Spirit closes in on her is about to eat
her when Scarlet or former contracted
Spirit intercepts and tries to fight it
but gets eaten after Scarlet disappears
Claire starts crying and blames herself
for its death as kameter charges towards
his opponent he summons his Spirit
causing it to transform into a long
sword memories of being the Legendary
Blade dancer Rena ashbell flood his mind
as he definitely slices the spirit in
two
after Scarlet's death she collapses on
the ground in despair crying and blaming
herself for not being strong enough to
protect her
Camino attempts to console her but he
faints as a result of overusing his
powers
Camino experiences a flashback in which
he along with several kids present
inside a hall is stabbing dummy humans
the shark dagger he is then taken to an
enclosed area with a girl in a small
frock standing across from him she
offers him her hand and his memory blurs
after he takes it hidden sees fleeting
glimpses of different memories like the
entire Hall burning down in a woman with
brown hair and a long sword looking at
him after going through a bright doorway
Kamina wakes up and sees a naked girl
with white hair sleeping beside him
startled he asks her who she is and she
tells him that she's s and belongs to
kamino calling him master
kamira tells her stop calling him that
and says that she should just call him
by his name he hears someone coming so
he tells her to quickly hide under the
sheets rinselet enters the room and asks
if he's all right now her maid tells him
that rinsley was worried about him and
carry him from astral zero herself
rinslet asks what the strange bump is
near his crotch area and takes his
sheets off she gets the wrong idea about
him and S and attacks him with her
spirit but s EAS easily controls and
pets it while revealing she is Camino's
contracted Spirit The Demon Slayer
kamiro takes us to school the next day
where she tells him that she is drawn to
him and likes him a lot Ellis arrives
and says that she was mistaken when she
thought that he was a decent man but he
quickly explains that S is his
contracted Spirit he then asks her how
her two friends are and she tells him
that you look cool when he fought the
demon spirit for Claire kamido asks her
where Claire is and she replies that she
might have gone to the military
Contracting ceremony taking place in the
city while heading towards the ceremony
Claire confronts a hooded figure who
approaches her and says that she can
give Claire a spirit in return for
helping awaken kamido Claire ends up
accepting her proposal and takes the Mad
Spirit Jesh Prince from her community
heads towards the blade dance for a
military Spirit Contracting ceremony
where Claire has participated thinking
about her older sister rubia elstain who
stole the strongest flame Spirit
levitame which burned the entire Kingdom
down people call her the calami queen
for single-handedly destroying the
entire Kingdom Claire is fighting a
large spirit with her wit but is unable
to defeat it because of not having a
contracted spirit and death inspiration
she accidentally lets Jesh Pence lose
which takes over scarla's body and
absorbs the other spirit's powers
Kamina reaches the arena and tells s to
transform into a blade so that he can
immobilize Scarlet he goes to Claire and
asks her if the current berserk form of
her spirit is the sword of power she
truly wants he says that if she desires
power that much he'd gladly be her
contracted Spirit moved by cameo's words
clear summons a fireball and presses it
to the spirit seal on her left hand
thereby causing pain to both her and
Scarlet while driving in pain kamido
slashes it with his blade causing it to
transform back into the standard Scarlet
from before
kamido asks Claire where she got the
frenzied Spirit from Jess's restia
abruptly appears in front of them she
unleashes the Caged military spirit
before flying away saying that she's
been waiting for three years kamido and
Claire managed to hide in a small Valley
as the spirit hatches she asks him what
rescue really means to him and he tells
her that she used to be his contracted
Spirit to decide to defeat the Spirit by
themselves and Claire kisses him they
face the spirit and communal shows off
the moves he learned back when he was
Ren ashebell by stabbing his eye Claire
manages to immobilize it with her Whip
and kamino finishes it off with a final
slash before he falls unconscious once
again he wakes up with s beside him when
Claire enters and misunderstands he
tries to explain himself but Ellis and
rinslet also enter the room Claire asks
him if he has any last words as all of
them draw their weapons on him meanwhile
a girl enters the academy in a cart
declaring that she finally found renash
Bell
adolescent girl called Fiona is
attempting to subdue his Spirit while
she flees she tries to summon her
contracted Spirit to his sister but
fails and trips on the ground
she believes she is doomed and prepares
to die when a young Camino intervenes to
save her by chopping away the spirit's
hand
he instructs her to remain still while
he uses his sword to defeat the coast
with ease the girl says she recognizes
the sword is belonging to Ren ashbell
the greatest blade dancer in history
realizing that he's been caught Camino
explains to her that he dresses as a
woman for the blade dances and warns her
not to tell anybody or he'll be in
trouble
the two agree to keep his secret and
kamido leads her out of the woods and
tells her his real name before they part
ways fienna visits the school many years
later in his search it appears that the
school's blade dance is a collaborative
effort rather than a 1v1 battle but it's
difficult for kamido and Claire to make
a team because of Claire's bossy
attitude so they are put up to fight
against a team of five in training the
pair ultimately loses after being slowed
down by four of the team's members and
finally being eliminated by the fifth
member's devastating strike
despite her customary attitude rinslet
joins the group along with s for lunch
Carol observes that her mistress too
needs a team because her demeanor also
pushes everyone else away like Claire
encouraged by kamido Claire extends an
invitation to rinslit to join their team
however the kind gesture quickly
deteriorates into an ego-based argument
and as the two are arguing Ellis arrives
to interrogate kamido
Ellis says that she wants Camino to join
her team for the blade dance while the
two girls remain quiet she was almost
driven Away by Claire's possessive
Behavior but kamino reasonably explains
to her that he's decided to stay with
the troubled young redhead
Ellis appears to act rationally as she
calmly accepts the rejection of her
offer and tells Cameo that the principal
called for him he reaches greyworth's
office and sees Fiona sitting there he
briefly argues with grayworth about his
seemingly unknown history and the
discussion eventually leads to Fiona
being introduced while she remembers
communal Crystal Clear he is unable to
recall exactly how many girls he has
saved throughout his lifetime but Gray
worth the points kamido's hardly
non-existent team to serve as Fiona's
escorts after learning that she is from
a prominent Noble family kamino bows to
Fiona apologizing for his rude behavior
and greyworth tells him that four years
ago they elected Fiona to be the
successor of the former Spirit princess
rubia elstain but she declined and
stepped down from the position because
of which she was disowned by the Royal
Family
kamiro asks great worth if his job is to
only guard and protect Fiona and she
tells him that it's beneficial for him
as well since it can Elevate his teen
rankings kamiro asks for the details and
greyworth tells him that he has to go to
a mining town called Gad to investigate
some earthquakes happening there he asks
her why the mission is of such a high
rank when he only has to investigate
earthquakes to which he tells him this
because there might be a military level
Spirit there
rayward further tells him that if the
seal on that spirit is undone then Fiona
will have to perform a spirit dance to
calm it down
he heads down the corridor with Fiona
when Claire sees them and takes him to
her room after seeing Claire's and
Camino's chemistry Fiona confronts her
and asks her what her relationship is
with him she tells her that he's her
slave Spirit which enrages Fiona to the
point that she challenges Claire to a
duel
the two decide to have a cook-off and
present their dishes to the judges AKA
Scarlet EST and comito
Claire Burns her food which is a result
obviously tastes bad Fiona comes up next
and serves her white stew as Claire
takes a first bite she collapses onto
her table which automatically declares
fian the winner later Claire is sleeping
off the fever she got from the stew and
Camino is taking a bath when Fiona
enters the bathroom in a swimsuit and
starts washing his back Claire wakes up
from all the noise they're making and
after seeing what they're trying to do
she joins in as well and both of them
start washing his back
suddenly s enters saying that something
bad is happening outside on the school
grounds all the knights have been
defeated and Ellis is tiredly fighting a
cloaked figure who seems to be playing
with her like a toy it's about to kill
her when Camino and Claire arrive they
attack together but Claire gets left
behind while kamino catches up to him
they start fighting and he finds out
that he has four contracted Spirits the
man says that he is Geo inzagi the
successor to the Demon Lord when Claire
fires multiple Fireballs at him which he
manages to dodge fienna rise to save
kamino but Geo forms a light Spear and
throws it at her from which kamito
manages to save her
Geo then runs away taking some
high-profiled sealed documents with him
Fiona is fighting rubia elstain so she
summons her Elemental Spirit which is a
gigantic silver Knight when she suddenly
wakes up in a bed Cameo enters the Rune
and they talk about the events of the
last night when he says that he needs to
ask her something important Claire comes
inside and he jumps out of the window
carrying Fiona meanwhile rinsley is
roaming the grounds with Carol when she
notices Claire sneaking after kamido and
Fiona and confronts her about it
Camino is walking in the forest with
Fiona and asks her how she knows his
real identity AKA Ren Ash Bell Fiamma
gives him a few hints and he finally
remembers who she is
Fiona tells him that he was her first
love and tells him that the only reason
she came here was because she wanted to
join his team in the blade dance and
when to reclaim her position and honor
Fiona asks him if he's mad but he says
that greyworth uses him all the time and
Claire treats him like a slave so it
doesn't bother him anymore
Ellis finds them talking and Camino asks
her what she's doing she tells him that
they're going to the mining town to
capture the recent Intruder he asks her
if she would like to operate together
since he and Fiona are also headed there
but she declines
later kamido rinselet and Claire meet in
front of the school gate and rinslet
bids farewell to Carol Fiona arrives
struggling to control a horse and meets
the others
they reached the town which is
completely abandoned and delve inside a
dungeon where an unbinding ritual was
performed recently they hear fighting
and try to locate the source of the
noise meanwhile Ellis is trying to fight
Geo easily defeats and knocks her to the
ground
and the others arrive and he takes out
his sword to fight but Geo releases
poisonous gas all over the area which
makes breathing almost impossible
Ellis painfully gets up and manages to
land a powerful blow which deeply
infuriates him he tries to kill her but
kamido and Claire stop him Gio and
kamino both ready their swords and dive
at each other kamiro asks him what his
true goal is and he replies that he just
wants to defeat him and become the true
successor to the Demon Lord as their
fight it's more and more intense Amino
breaks Geo's swords one after another
but every time one of them breaks he
takes another one out Claire tries to
assist him but Geo sends a large ball of
ice at her which knocks her down he also
heavily injures Rin slits so an anger
Camino is about to defeat him with his
sword when it reduces in size because of
overuse Geo tells kamido that he isn't
as strong as he once was and throws a
lightning spear at a defenseless Fiona
and Ellis kamir stands in front of them
and manages to block the blast but gets
heavily injured due to direct contact
Geo says that the reason he is so weak
now is that he has friends and
companions he wants to protect he gets
ready to summon his strongest Spirit
Thanatos which he says was given to him
by restia when Fiamma intercepts and
uses her Bloodstone to blast him with
her increased power
most of the cave gets destroyed and Geo
manages to get away Claire asks Fiona
why she never used her contracted spirit
and Fiona tells them that she lost her
contracted Spirit four years ago and
used Spirit Stones to get into the
academy
as they are talking the cave starts to
slightly tremble they think of a way to
get to the true Altar and S tells them
that she knows the real location of the
altar so they leave rinslit Ellis and
her friends behind and head to the
location
they reached the Altar and Fiona tells
them that she has to purify herself
before dancing
so the two girls decide to take a bath
while Cameo keeps watch outside
Geo later arrives at the gate and kamita
faces him with est he easily overpowers
him but when Geo attacks s with his
Spirit kamiro tries to protect her and
get stabbed in the chest but it was all
part of their plan Fiona starts her
spirit dance bombing all the spirits
inside Geo and rendering him incapable
of attacking Geo collapses to the ground
and restia materializes near him he asks
her to give him one last chance and she
changes into her sword form
charges at him and Gio releases a large
blast that he easily Dodges but Chio was
intending to hit Fiona from the
beginning and Camino runs in front of
her getting hit by the brute force of
rescue's dark power instead
Fiona falls into despair for having
risked cameo's life twice and
desperately calls upon her contracted
Spirit which surprisingly comes to her
Aid and helps them defeat Geo
Kamina wakes up in a bed again but with
Fiona this time around who tells him
that they handed Geo over to the
military and managed to reveal your
manganer Ellis is watching from the
stands as her sister fights and quickly
gets defeated by renash Bell in the
present day Kamina wakes up and checks
to see if there's someone sleeping with
him this time as well and thankfully
there isn't Claire and Fiona are making
chocolates for him outside and Fiona
puts crushed Newt inside her mixture
saying that it also acts as an
aphrodisiac and kamido would go mad with
lust after idiot Claire tries to stop
her but Burns her own chocolate in the
process
later comedo along with Claire and Fiona
as having a battle against some other
elementalers meanwhile Claire takes out
another opponent when a water spirit
rises from a puddle near them and grabs
Fiona who quickly summons her spirit and
takes out their final enemy they head
back and decide to get lunch but two of
the girls they defeated try to provoke
Claire into fighting them so that she
could get disqualified from the blade
dance but rinselet arrives and insults
them before they run away kamiro heads
to his supplementary class for
foundations and sees Ellis there as well
he tells her the important key bits to
memorize from her book and she asks if
he could tutor him so he agrees to meet
her in the garden at five as all of them
are heading towards the restaurant
Camino notices Claire checking out a
necklace and rinselet tells him that
it's her birthday tomorrow Kamina versus
Ellis walking outside and he and Claire
start bickering kamido awaits Ellis in
the garden and she promptly arrives upon
her arrival Ellis inquires whether they
can study in her room
Camino can sense and they make their way
to her Abode Ellis goes to get ready
before they start their lesson while
kamio notices a ren ashebell frame on
her table he decides to keep his true
identity a secret as he knows it would
upset her when Ellis returns she is
dressed as a maid and offers to cook him
a meal as a way of thanking him for his
help with the silford commuto
compliments her cooking and says that
she would make a great wife after eating
they'd returned to the Garden where
Ellis tells Camino about her sister's
defeat in the blade dance four years ago
Ellis asks kamino if you would like to
join the silford and he agrees asking if
he could get paid in advance when he
returns Claire is still making chocolate
and asked him about his time with Ellis
Camuto tells her everything but Claire
becomes upset and thinks that he doesn't
value her she tells him to leave and
finds Fiona comforting her later
Kamina wakes up in a ruined Shack with s
by his side she calls him Oni Chan and
asks if he is mad at her but he
reassures her that he isn't a promises
not to leave her again
Ellis is instructing the guards on their
duties from the Valencia festival and
introducing kamido as the new member
when her elder sister valseria returns
belseria insults Ellis and comedo stands
up for her belseria attacks them with a
wind blast causing most of the knights
to collapse she recruits the ones who
still standing into her team and asks
kamido to join as well but he declines
belseria threatens to destroy him before
leaving
later while eating with Ellis kamido
sees Scarlet watching him and runs after
her leading him to Claire Claire asks
him to take her to a cafe but he
declines because he's busy patrolling
the city she becomes upset throws her
bag at him and runs away in anger and
jealousy while walking home Clara gets
approached by an aqua-haired woman on
the other hand Hamido is patrolling the
streets with Ellis when he grabs her
hand to stop her from falling giving her
the wrong idea he asked her what made
her join the knights to which she
replies that she did because she always
aspired to become like her sister who
has always been her role model but her
sister changed after she lost her battle
against Ren ashebell kamido asks her if
she hates Ash Bell but Ellis denies
saying that her swordsmanship looked
like she was wheeled in her sword for
someone else rather than any personal
gain
later kamiro asked her if she would mind
coming shopping with him for a bit
meanwhile the woman traps Claire and
asks her if she would like undefeated
power but Claire uses Scarlett to push
her away and tries to attack her before
she shows her the girls who tried to
bully her earlier
she tells her that they asked for the
power and she simply gave it to them she
then proceeds to bring out a dark spirit
that starts attacking Claire meanwhile
Camino buys the necklace Claire was
checking out earlier as a gift for her
birthday when he observes a massive fire
nearby upon investigating they find his
Spirit on the loose it tries to assault
a little girl akamino defends her and is
wounded in his chest as a result when
Claire arrives another spirit is also
pursuing her the three of them have
already decided to fight together and
are set to strike when valseria shows up
and begins blasting both the spirits and
the people out of her way kamino
confronts her when she criticizes Ellis
but she blows him aside knocking him out
cold he wakes up and eats some of
Claire's chocolate before she enters the
room to check up on him gives her the
necklace you bought for her birthday and
she apologizes for her rude Behavior
both of them are about to kiss when
Fiona enters the room and tells them
that their opponent for the final match
is valseria's team who they're going to
be fighting tomorrow they are thinking
about how they're going to fight her
long-range weapons when rinslet says
that she can join their team and use her
bow and arrow to fight
it later convinced Ellis to join their
team as well and finalize their
strategies meanwhile belseria meets the
woman who attacked Claire who tells her
that the most she will be able to live
is two to three years in valseria says
that it doesn't matter as long as she
can fight the blade dance Claire Ellis
rinsley and Fiona travel to astral zero
to fight belseria the battle begins and
they seem to be under control for the
most part and destroyed two of her
protection's legs but velsaria goes into
frenzy and unleashes the cursed seal
placed at her heart team Scarlett tries
to fight her but she grabs them all and
starts absorbing their Divine energy
Ellis the only one remaining tries to
use her spirit to attack belseria but
she easily grabs her and is about to
attack her when kamido comes to the
Rescue by slashing valseria's arm off
and saving the other girls as well he
starts fighting belseria and mostly
takes the upper hand but he quickly
starts tiring out sir Fiona uses the
last of her power to heal his past
wounds and the other girls help
immobilize her so that Cameo can deliver
the final blow together they are finally
able to defeat belseria Eva meanwhile
greyworth kills the woman who implanted
that cursed seal into valseria and meets
restia who tells her that she won't let
kamido do what she wants after enjoying
a victory party team Scarlet embarks on
their Journey to the blade dance
tournament fully prepared for the
upcoming battles ahead